hi this is pressure Locker let's go over
four methods to subtract numbers that
are part of the common core curriculum
one method is subtracting numbers from
right to left this is the traditional
method let's say you want to do 360
minus 156 we start from the far right
and we see if we can take away 6 from 0
since 6 is larger than 0 we need to
carry over so this 6 from the tens
column becomes a 5 and the 0 becomes a
10 now we subtract column by column 10
minus 6 is 4 5 minus 5 is 0 and 3 minus
1 is 2 so we have 204 another method is
to subtract numbers left to right this
is very good for mental math so let's
say you want to do the same problem we
subtract the first digit which is 1 so
we have 360 minus 100 in our head we
store 260 then we need to subtract 50
which gets us to 210 and then finally we
subtract 6 which gets us to 204 so this
looks complicated but it can be good for
mental math a third method is known as
Singapore and you don't need to carry
over the numbers so let's say we want to
do 360 minus 156 this 6 is greater than
a 0 so to avoid this we'll subtract 6
from each number so from 360 we're going
to subtract 6 which gets us 354 and from
156 we also subtract 6 which gets us to
150 now to do this problem we can
subtract column by column so 4 minus 0
will be 4 5 minus 5 is 0 and 3 minus 1
is 2 so the great thing about the
Singapore method is you don't have to
carry over a final method is known as
counting up and this is often good for
if you want to give change so let's say
you buy an item costing off dollar 56
and you give 3 dollars and 60 cents
how will they know how much change to
give well first they can give you four
cents which brings your total two
hundred ones dollar sixty cents then
they might give you forty cents which
brings you to two dollars then they
might give you a dollar which brings the
total to three dollars and finally
they'll give you another sixty cents
which gets us to 360 so how much change
has the cash you're giving you in total
we add up the blue numbers so four plus
40 plus the dollar plus 60 is two
dollars and four cents I hope you liked
this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on Twitter at pressure Locker and you
can get my books at Amazon